welcome to recreating forgotten
programming languages fart I'm your host
for today my name is Sherman and my
pronouns are she and her Sherman is a
little bit of a weird first names but
two words in it and this is space in
between and the downside of having like
a weird name is that people are
Starbucks never get it right but it's
okay because if you google my name I'm
the first search result and I didn't
have to do anything so free SEO games
yeah so nice to meet you you can tell
from my accent and also my name that I'm
not really from around here I'm actually
from a small country in Southeast Asia
called Malaysia but I actually now live
in New York City where I first moved to
to attend something called a recurse
Center and it's a programís retreat in
New York City if you have not heard of
it before it's completely free and it's
a place where you can go to to spend
either one six or 12 weeks to rediscover
the joy programming it's completely self
direct that you can do whatever you want
as long as you're programming and I
always plug them at the beginning of my
talks because the other reason why I'm
here today they gave me the space to
explore lots of creative programming and
so that sounds really interesting to you
you should definitely go check it out
make your Center yeah and as you can
tell from the title of the talk I loved
two things
programming and art so during the day my
day job is as a senior a web platform
engineer and at night I like making art
and that sometimes involves drawing
comics or you know just doodling and I
like combining these two things
programming and art together and it's
mostly used to create something called
computer art which is a really broad
term and I like to define it as any art
that in which computers play a role in
the production or the display of that
look and if you think I'll computer out
today when I mentioned it a lot of
people think about Photoshop or
illustrator or like 3d graphics or games
they are VR art or machine learning art
that's you know what we think of today
but for the talk about gif we're gonna
be really focusing on the birth of
computer
so I'm gonna give you a little bit of a
crash course off computer history some
of the interesting things that I've
learned about it and we're specifically
going to focus on the era of the 1950s
to 1970s the reason being this was when
computer graphics were first becoming a
thing when computers were first getting
advanced enough that you could use them
to create graphics individuals and of
course create art before we talk about
computer art we first need to talk about
what computers were like back then and
the reason why we have two is because
context really matters when we are
talking about art as I show you the
pieces later on I want you to think
about who were the people who were
making these pieces of art what kind of
technologies that they have available to
them and why would a making it and it's
really easy to look at these pieces and
because they you know made good 60 70
years ago the graphics are not gonna be
very sophisticated and it's easy to
dismiss it but if you keep in mind what
was available back then in terms of
technology and also intentions they
become really interesting so context
really matters and I hope to provide you
with a little bit of it before we start
so computers back then were really large
they would take up entire rooms and
here's an example of a popular computer
that was introduced in 1959 for a very
affordable price of three million
dollars today you can buy a computer for
you know less than three thousand
dollars and if you come for inflation
this would cost about 30 million today
so computers are really expensive and
the only people that could afford them
where research facilities or
universities or militaries so they're
not really accessible or affordable and
that really limited the kind of people
that have access to them in order to
interface a computer most of the time
you would have to work with punch cards
and what you would do is that you have
to type at your code on to punch cards
get a little stack of punch cards to
describe your program and run it so like
a typical workflow be like okay you go
to the computer center look up
documentation on paper type it out and
you get like a stack of punch cards and
then you take it to a little man behind
the door and five minutes later
magically you get a drawing back so
people wouldn't even really interface
with the computer much they just has
someone running for them and if you
think five minutes is a long time to
wait for you know something to run you
might have to wait like ADEA - if
someone else's program is running there
was like one computer and get away for
your turn so if you ever get impatient
waiting for your program to build think
about this
yeah and output devices were really
limited but very interesting so they
were line printers I'll talk a little
bit more about this but this would be
the most common form of output you
opinio output onto paper and in carry
around view there were cathode ray tubes
or CRT displays which was not unlike you
know the TV sets that you have in the
80s and 90s so this might look a little
familiar and then you had something
really interesting called microfilmed
plotters or electronic plotters and
here's an example of one the Stromberg
Carlson 40:20 microfilm recorder and the
way that I work is kind of similar to
how a CRT display will work but instead
of displaying like the graphics onto a
screen it would expose it onto microfilm
which is a small format film which you
can then print a series off and use it
to enemy and we'll talk a little bit
more about this leader there's also
mechanical plotters that were basically
drawing robots that had a pen on a robot
arm that can move across the surface of
a paper and this is really great for
drawing graphics that had very intricate
line base vector graphics and so you can
tell from from the kinds of output
devices that were available that
computers who really mainly use for
scientific and mathematical applications
these were not devices that were
designed to make splashy graphics and
that was because that was what computers
were mostly used for by researchers
academics and the military Boeing was
actually a real pioneer in computer
graphics and they actually coined the
term computer graphics itself they would
use it and I think this was what's in
the mid 60s to simulate the positioning
of pilots within a cockpit to assist
with plane designs this is very this
cutting edge I think is from 1963 they
were use computer graphics to simulate
endings of flights and the first-ever
airport that was soonly that was a
seattle-tacoma f1 bell Epps was another
hotbed of computer graphics research and
they actually meet one of the very first
computer-generated films and I'm gonna
show it to you and it's here
super cute it's a simulation of a to
gyro gravity gradient attitude control
system by he's a jock meet in 1963 and
this here shows a simulation of a
satellite across a planet and this was
revolutionary at a time because prior to
this if you wanted to create animation
you would have to draw each frame by
hand and stitch it all together in order
to create animation but this is
completely computer-generated and it was
a really big deal at the time
so those are some practical applications
now let's talk about some retro vintage
computer art so not in order to get a
feel of what computer I was like back
then I look to a couple of magazines the
first ving computers and automation and
this was a magazine that I ran from the
1950s to 1988 quite a long run and this
was the computer magazine at the time
it's like the wired or like the hacker
news of today and who else edited by
Edmund Berkeley and they were the very
first people who ran a computer art
competition back in 1963 so even in the
really early days of computer graphics
they recognized computer art was a
really interesting thing and it was
worth showcasing and so they did that
and it ran this competition or Expo
annually for every August are issued I
here you can see some examples of covers
from the exhibitions you can tell
they're all black and white because
color graphics were not available back
then
hello it was geometric line base also
very abstract the art competition a
computer competition was directed by a
woman named Gracie Hartline who was a
educator at the California State
University who was herself an
established computer artist and a
pioneer in the field and she ran it for
a good 19 years I believe so she a
Harley and she went on to publish
another magazine that was the magazine
for computer graphics and art and it was
solely dedicated to the field and this
is a really great magazine if you want
to get an idea of what cutting-edge
graphics were like back then if you look
through some of the pieces that was
submitted a lot of them like I said
black and white geometric minimally is
you know today you call them like lo-fi
retro and mostly very simple and flat
but still interesting to look at and I
was really fascinated by this because
even though they were mean if limited
technology but you can't help but look
at them and be like hey that's really
cool I wonder how it was me and so I
actually went down this rabbit hole of
trying to reverse engineer and recreate
some retro computer art it was a really
interesting thing to look at and it was
a little bit of a brain
to look at something and be like oh how
would you get something effect like this
using computer and programming so it
spent a lot of time arduous engineering
this stuff and on the left here here's
an example of a realization of a
calculus problem that results in a
really interesting Kiley and the thing
to note is that a lot of early computer
artists were actually scientist and
mathematicians because those are people
access to computers and they often
feature works of art that displayed are
demonstrated mathematical concepts
because we found them interesting and
they are also really beautiful over here
I have some recreation of Ramona another
pioneer in computer art and she was
making generative or algorithms based
drawings before computers were a thing
so that was really fun to reverse
engineer as well
there were several challenges in trying
to understand how these works of art
will meet the number one being that
there's no source code this is before I
get hot so there was no like a link to
repo here and a lot of times the pieces
were published with just the final
output sometimes they'll be brief
descriptions of the technique or the
concepts being Illustrated and most all
time do we meet with defunct languages
and devices so even if I could get a
source code for something that will run
on the IBM 7090
I don't have an IBM 7090 unfortunately
so I couldn't run it and it became a fun
thing to try to recreate it with like
modern D languages
as I worked on yeast I realized that
there was a really interesting question
of how do these programming languages
influence the work it's really easy to
see how the output devices like printers
are CRT displays how that could
influence the final aesthetic on pieces
but I was interested in how programming
languages affected the way that the
computer artists were thinking about the
work so that series that oh the spoken
language that you use affects the way in
which you think and think that's
something analogous to that with
programming languages a lot of computers
and devices as I mentioned before we're
really not meant for making art and so a
lot of computer artists had to build
their own languages on tools to make it
easier to think in terms of graphics and
so I found it really interesting and
today's talk I'm going to show you two
different languages the first was a
language that was designed for artists
and the second was the first language
that was designed for creating moving
pictures or animations so let's jump
right into the first one some time back
I discovered this series of work by an
American artist Frederick famously from
1969 and you can tell immediately
looking at this that it's printed and
from the perforated edges of paper and
to me this was really interesting
because like they had a lot of texture
ingredients to the work and it was also
a while simple really interesting to
look at and I got really curious and
said look into howdy so neat and you
know what was the inspiration behind him
they were printed using a line printer I
mentioned this earlier and live printers
have its name from the fact that it
printed line by line and also he had a
very limited character set so this is a
example of a drum of a line printer you
had X number of characters and you could
just only print that and these were
actually are really fast and also really
loud I don't have audio but you can just
imagine it going and the perforations on
the paper were to help the printer hold
onto the paper to move it across the
drum
I also found out that these will meet
with a language called art one and if
you google it there's not a lot of
information out there except for the
fact that it is made by two people
Katherine Nash and Richard Williams at
the University of New Mexico Nash was
with the school of art and we Lim
supposed to the school of Electrical
Engineering because you know school so
computer science we're not thinking yet
like them and they collaborated are
making this language and this was a
really interesting language because it
was designed to teach students to make
simple computer graphics and it was
notable for the fact that its simplicity
and its intended primarily as an
introduction to the use of computers for
those without any technological
background and the idea that in a really
early days of the computer people
recognize it as a really powerful device
that could be used as a medium for
artists and it wasn't great that you
know to learn programming you had such a
high barrier to entry and so they
created this language to make it easier
for people without any tech background
to get into making graphics example of a
piece here that I really like it's
really interesting to look at because as
you zoom in the details of it revealed
that oh while you had this limited
character set on a printer they got
really creative and created extra layers
of texture by overlapping text so here
you can see like zeroes overlaps /
apostrophes and dots and also dashes and
I thought that was a pretty creative use
of a limited character set and so you
may be looking at this you're like ah we
have something like that today
you know it's called SP art haha and um
is it kind of similar and I think in a
way yes but also no in that a SP art
doesn't have the overlapping
characteristic and also this was
actually created on a very different
more limited character set call ebcdic
which tends to extended binary coded
decimal interchange code and it was the
character set that was available for IBM
computers at a time and it was much
smaller than asked me and so yeah I
thought this is a really good example of
art created by making the most out of
available technology and it was really
cool
I was also really interested in what art
1 was like because hey this is a
language that was designed for beginners
and uh it was really hard to find
documentation on it the only place where
I could find documentation was in a book
title the computer in art which is not
really online but you can find it at
some libraries and this was published by
just IREC taught in 1971 and it's a
really good book on the zeitgeist of the
movement back then
and in it there were about ten pages
describing the art one language and the
idea was really simple you have to erase
and each area was 105 by 50 characters
and you can draw things into each array
and later on as it was output they would
print one array over the other what can
you draw and erase so there are
literally seven drawing subroutines you
could draw seven different types of
things lines solid rectangles open
rectangles triangles it exists quadrants
which were mirrors of each quadrant and
exponential curve exponential curves and
the documentation for drawing a line
look like this and it was pretty
straightforward you would say where each
row and column you run your line to
start at and also how many columns and
lines it would traverse and you also say
which I really want to draw this in and
also what character to draw this line
with so with that ten pages
documentation I have no idea how the
underlying mechanics were method I meet
a little implementation of it we've
JavaScript I could have written it
interpreter for it but I decided to use
JavaScript because I like language and
also this was the easier route so real
talk
I ran into several problems the first
being I don't own a printer um and
today's peanuts don't really quite work
the same as line printers so the
solution to that was to okay what's the
next best thing that I have that is free
achievement you know works kind of like
a printer and it was like ah the
terminal ha ha ha it outputs text has a
limited character set you could output
it line by line good enough it's free
and the problem with terminal is that
it's not really meant for creating
overlapping text unless you use a
library like and krisis
it doesn't really have easy way to
overlay text
because that's not what you usually do
and so I was like okay fine
what can I do with my existing character
set and then decided to get a little bit
creative of it so the character set we
have on most computers today is the
Unicode and Unicode turns out has a
series of characters called are critical
marks which are used to add accents on
to single with characters and the way
this work is that let's say you have a
single character and if you would like
to add an accent to it you add a Unicode
diacritical mark and that would add a
little accent on your character but
still keep the width to a single
character and I was like huh yes kind of
laughing I'll take it aha
and um so I'm gonna show you a little
demo of like what that overlapping
future looks like let's see oh no don't
look at my really messy desktop okay
there we go all right so let's say here
I have a little program that have some
setup code here and it's going to render
a little grid of twenty by twelve
characters and drawing a square of four
by four in the middle here if I wanted
to create an overlapping square all I
gotta do is draw another rectangle and
instead of rendering like a character
like this particular square here is
rendering the small old character I'm
rendering a diacritical dark critical
unicode character here which is a little
square like thing I'll show you in a bit
and if I have that it creates a
interesting overlapping over that thing
in fact and you can do this with any of
the their critical marks and get really
interesting fun effects so that's just
how that looks like
all right so here are some things that I
came up with this is made with just
triangles and it's really interesting to
note that because of how low fidelity
this is like even the gaps between of
triangles end up looking around it so
there was like a nice little side effect
and also in terminal I have colors so
you can put your round of it here's what
I meet with mostly circles
here's another meet with mostly lines
drawing lines is very fun I'll get into
that later but a lot of a detail is
really achieved by using the dark
critical marks and also emojis because
the movies are good and so we have some
really cool so lines one of the things I
had learned when creating this library
was how to draw a lines so we cannot
think drawing lines for granted it's
like well from point A to point B let's
just draw a straight line but turns out
when you're trying to draw a line on a
grid it's a little bit more complicated
than that because your grid might not
have a high high enough resolution for
your life to look smooth so how do you
approximate a line on a grid and for
this I use something called the pressing
high pressing x line drawing algorithm
which was first implemented in 1962 and
they have since been other line dry dry
algorithms but they were invented later
in the decades and I was like oh nice
things too it's period-appropriate let's
use this so we have a grid of let's say
pixels and I want to draw a line and
this is in this case a line has a very
gentle slope and it has a positive
gradient so really your pixels would go
if you're starting here it will either
go up or to the right and in order to
approximate this and what you would do
is that you would start at a point any
point where your line you when you're
like to start and because of the slope
of this line you can really only go in
two directions either you go to the
right or you go up by one and in order
to choose which direction to go in the
way that you would decide is by figuring
out if the error between these two
points like which one of these were was
larger than the other so in this case
the lower one will introduce a lower
error of 0.4 assuming like each pixel
here has value
one and so because this point is closer
to the line than the one at the top
we're gonna choose it and we're gonna
note that oh now when I draw this line
it's going to be a little bit lower than
what it's supposed to be so you have to
keep track of this error and as you keep
as you draw the next point you take into
consideration the fact that okay now the
lines a little bit lower than what it
should be if I choose the next line the
next point I need to take the
consideration if this is going to make
the error worse in this case it makes
sense to choose the one at the top
because it's the closest and also the
fact that the point now is lowered in
line choosing one on top would help
correct that error and so I choose that
and now I have an error of a much
smaller area where my point is a little
bit higher than what the line should be
to repeat this over and over again and
you get approximation of the line there
we go and so this was actually really
fun to work on because this is something
that you take for granted like when you
use drawing libraries like oh well you
have a line subroutine and you draw it
but you don't really think about how
does that appear actually on pixels in
the screen this is really cool
yeah so that's art one and now I'm gonna
talk to you about a language for moving
pictures so remember the first computer
animated animation meet my Bell Labs
this was a product of a researcher at
Bell Labs and at the same time they meet
they published a video on a computer
technique for the production of animated
movies and this was me by researcher Ken
Knowlton at Bell Labs and it was a 14
minute silent video on how to use
computers to make movies and remember
this is the first time anyone has ever
done this and it was really cool
in the video he described a language
called deathless which was implemented
in Fortran using macros and it worked on
the IBM 7090 in conjunction with the
Stromberg Carlson
40:20 microfilm plotter and the way that
work is that you would have a stack of
cards to describe your movie feed it
into the computer output the
instructions to a magnetic tape which
would that was then fed into the
microfilm plotter to plot or draw your
frames
it's called ethics because it's shut for
Bell flicks
there's not a lot information about the
language online and whenever I google
for like Netflix like you'll try to
correct me to Netflix and I was like
close but not quite apart by sixty
decades ahaha and creative I can open at
Bell Labs in New Jersey and here's an
example of on the left over here as a
peace meet with ethics and this was in
1963 also the year that the computer art
competition first started so this is
really an era where this was really
sudden diversion and thus in fact looks
something would look something like this
where you could use loops in order to
animate things you could draw a square
and an update location and draw the next
frame and that was very interesting so
you could do fun things like this where
you could create you write a word with
characters and it's important to note
here that the microfilm photo was also
not really designed for creating
graphics it was designed for outputting
text and so you also had a limit that
character set and there wasn't really an
idea of like oh like light to dark
pixels you just had different characters
and so no time we use different
characters to represent different shades
and you can do fun things like bounce
this each character around the screen
and you end up this and I'm like the
effect I love the fact that the low
resolution makes it interesting
uh-huh and this is only really Kim
available because of the low resolution
of the microphone plotter and the
graininess of it so those little bit of
a problem
death Lex had a really high learning
curve but a lot of non-technical artists
especially we're really interested in it
they're like hey this is really cool can
we make some cool art of it but it was a
lot to pick up if you did not have any
technological background to come to that
Knowlton actually work with artists and
residents at Bell Labs to create a new
language called explore and exploits
kind of interesting and weird and I'm
gonna tell you a little bit about it it
was actually made with artistic
intentions in mind and so if you see on
the on the left here there's a piece
from a August issue of computers on
automation that won the first place in
the computer art contest there was meat
explore are created by artists Lillian
Schwartz with Ken Knowlton
bit more of a [ __ ] leader and Explorer
was interesting because it was a
probabilistic language and it was
transliteration beast and I'll talk
about these two things in a little bit
the way it worked was that you had a
grid of 340 by 240 cells in which you
could add values to the cells the values
could be easier to 9 or Hz and you could
met those values to color so in this
case there'll be a command for you to
map values 0 to 4 to white pixels or
light pixels and 5 to 9 to black and ABC
X Y Z 2 to twinkles and tinkles were
pixels that would either be black or
white on the frame depending like at the
randomness of a 50/50 and oh and also if
you look at this come on you see here a
little extra part here with open paren
and comma P and this was a probabilistic
indicator and this was a really
interesting feature of the language so
the probabilistic indicator would tell
the computer how likely this line should
be run so if you run something at the
rate of like 101 times it will always
run it but you can also run it at a
probability of like 1 over 16 or you
could say Oh run this every fourth time
or every eight times roof site or except
for the 5500 etc time do it and so you
had this really interesting controls on
determining the probability of something
being run so randomness was really baked
into the language which is something
that I haven't really seen before it
also had an interesting feature of
changing values by transliteration so
transliterate literary transliteration
it's a mouthful and it's the idea that
you have a lookup table over here that
looks something like this where you say
oh net values a to b and value C to B
and a way to read this one come on is
that for each cell with the
probabilistic indicator of 2 comma 1 for
every other time this line is is reached
choose about one third of the cells and
if it has a value a method to be if it
has a value C method to be
you can also do really complicated
conditions for when to translatory so
for example you could say you can use
adjacency condition transliteration and
this is a lot I'm gonna break it down
which basically says Oh for each cell
you know with a probability of one over
four if they are exactly two three or
four neighbors in a cell in a north east
south or west positions of itself whose
value is either a a B C or D then you
know you probably the about like one
fifth update the current cell of the
values six five to six and seven to
eight and so I was reading this and I
was like okay that's interesting about
but what can you do this like why would
you want these features and turns out
having randomness and transliteration
baked in is really cool for simulating
natural phenomena so here's an example
of the simulation of expanding Fringe
visual phosphines
and visual phosphines a weird thing
happens when for example when he close
your eyes and you press your fingers on
your eyelids you see like flashes of
light and they were trying to simulate
this phenomena and if you see the
instructions over here they're mostly
transliteration instructions and just
six lines and how it worked was it was
scatter a random number of nuclei around
the grid and for each nuclei it would
expand over time and every at every
point each part of the fringe had a
probability of becoming a new nuclei and
so it would grow and create this pattern
of simulation you can also simulate
regular and irregular snowflake
crystallization instead of a square grid
Explorer had a hex mode which was agreed
on a hex on hexagonal grid and also
using the same transliteration
instructions
you could simulate the growth pattern of
snowflakes and I thought this is really
cool because it's not a lot lines of
code even though they were a little hard
to understand but the fact that you
create something like this with the
basic features of the language with
randomness baked in was really
interesting
so I'm still working on implementation
of my Explorer there are there's not a
lot of documentation on Explorer
available either there are two papers on
it and I'm working on those so if you're
interested in finding out more or if you
would like to take a crack at it
you know come talk to me and super happy
to talk to you about it I want to share
view before we close a work by Leland
Schwarz which was a pioneer of computer
art at Bell Labs who worked really
closely with Knowlton on the explore
language who really pushed the
boundaries of it
she made this video with northern pedal
pixelation and it was combination of
computer generated graphics and also and
alot graphics with port paint and I
highly recommend watching this on Vimeo
there's a link to the source there
because there is a soundtrack it's
really cool and yeah this is like one of
the earliest pieces of computer
animation art
so I want to talk a little bit about why
computer history like why the why bother
learning about it why am i giving this
talk why am I telling you all about this
stuff a Python effect is really
interesting I think
there is an a little bit of an
unfortunate phenomenon in tech where we
are constantly focused on what's new and
what's hot and what's you know the next
shiny thing that we don't really talk
about the history of it as I was
learning all the stuff I realized that
we never really learned this in school
or even you know anywhere and yet there
were a lot of really interesting things
being done interesting work being done
and a lot of it was also it was relevant
at a time I think is also still relevant
today and it's really hard to know where
to go if you don't know where you've
been
if you don't know what people people are
try and learning about like art one and
ethics and explore and understanding
that oh you know it's really important
to have languages that are accessible
was you know that's still really a thing
that is relevant to thee and so it's
really trusting to look back at what has
been tried out and where we've come from
and have a lot more appreciation for
where we are today because of that in
one of the papers that describe the art
one language the co-authors mentioned
that the program was given the name art
one not only to signify that they may be
an art too but also to symbolize the
four full interactions of the Arts and
Technology are legion they may be at
someday and art 1000 and while there was
an art too they did actually make an art
too there is no art 1000 I like to think
that we kind of got there and there are
languages out here today that kinda
represent that so processing p5
openFrameworks
like all languages that were designed to
make it easy for you to create graphics
that were big enough friendly and I
think the creators of art one would have
been really happy to see where we've
come from and where we've gotten to
today so it's really cool and that's all
I have for you thank you so much for
coming to this talk I'm really glad that
you decided to attend and I have my
contact details here if you would like
to keep in touch or if you found it
interesting and have anything to share
I'll be hanging around
this room here for the next talk as well
and also for a little bit during lunch
time so I really love to meet you if you
would like this come say hi but yeah
otherwise find me on Twitter or email
thank you so much